by doing
look everybody is trying to mitigate
risk and hedge against vulnerabilities I
run into them
let me just
I run right the [ __ ] into them
I run right the [ __ ]
stoppable
[Music]
706 a.m. Singapore were supporting
generate morning show action here in
Asia
you get some sleep
squatting long
being 12 hours ahead and it sucks
because makeup too you know 146 emails
for fire just trying to catch up and
forget on fire hose
that's a fire coming in a fire hose not
like I could deal with
what does hustle mean to you why why is
it important for me it's important
because I don't think any of us in this
room or anybody reading this article can
physically change how smart they are I
don't think we can make ourselves you
know more clever or more strategic but I
do think that hard work is the most
controllable aspect of entrepreneurship
and business that anybody can deploy and
I find that fascinating right I'm just
willing to work until you guys feel
satisfied you know I'm not worried about
the margin you know what I mean and then
and then I would add one last thing I
would argue I'd rather somebody continue
to persevere around something they love
doing like if you love making ice cream
sundaes and you want to become the
number one expert of ice cream sundaes
with the hope of opening ice cream
sundae stores i weirdly would rather you
not all the way make it kind of live
paycheck paycheck to paycheck but be so
happy then go and do law be miserable
and make a little bit more money that
allows you to take a vacation or have a
fancy car so it's a complex question
some can argue to me that they are so
insecure that they need a Rolex and a
BMW and that's what scratches the itch
for them and I'm okay with that to me
you making eighty-seven thousand dollars
a year writing about eSports is more
attractive than making 210 as a
consultant in the way that I view life
it's the most controllable and I try to
give advice that is actually practical
and not makes me look cool and so that's
why I love hustle I am an unbelievable
buyer of the modern consumption patterns
of the consumer because I'm unemotional
while many in this room and many
watching at home are just trying to
figure out what to do in this
environment we are now in the pre-dawn
of our attention being shifted to audio
whether in podcast form or very soon
Alexa Google Apple devices that become
the AI ml voice interactions of our day
and whatever obviously $0.10 and Alibaba
do it in in the Asian markets this is
going to be the next frontier of
attention arbitrage and so I highly
recommend that you get far more
disciplined in your understanding on
where your actual customers attention is
and not be lazy and say well my customer
is older when my customer is richer
they're not on these platforms in that
naivete will become great detriment to
your ambitions and the nimbleness in my
lack of romance of what's working for me
today and the underlining work ethic and
humility that I deploy against the next
consumer trend I lack the audacity that
most of the people in this room have
about how they want it to be versus how
it actually is and I trade on that
currency it's practical to take high
risk between 20 and 30 now with the way
the Internet is structured it is smarter
to take high risk entrepreneurial
ventures between 20 and 30 now than to
go into a corporation and the main
reason 20 to 30 year olds still go into
a corporation is because of the scratch
that they have to itch itch that they
have to scratch to appease their parents
and that over indexes in Asia but it's
not practical you know young you are at
30 you know much opportunity there
actually is do you know how much you can
do if you're not willing to live fancy
and live humbly it's unbelievable
companies are in big trouble because the
feeding system of universities in
America they're in deep trouble because
I don't know the Singapore market but in
America there's an incredible heist and
fraud going on
it's called debt to go to university
there's nobody now at six I get a
thousand emails a thousand emails a week
DMS on Instagram from 16 year olds that
are like I'm a straight-a student my
parents want me to go to college I want
to be an entrepreneur
of course because it's cool and
most people can't be so I get it but
follow along my parents are poor and
they want me to go to this university to
make them feel good the amount of things
that people in this room have done
because of the insecurities of their
parents is stunning to me it's sad and
in America it's compounded because kids
are taking on $250,000 in debt with high
interest rates and aren't getting
anything when they come out that will
last and so what we're in listen how are
you not smart enough to realize there's
something called the Internet it's
finally hit some level of maturity
because now it's about 25 20 years old
consumer-facing
dude do we not realize how big of a it's
the single biggest thing that has
happened to the human race
it's arbitrage out the physical world
this is so much bigger than I think
we're quantifying I talked about the
communication and marketing aspects but
everything you see around blockchain and
Trump and brexit and China this is this
is the preview we haven't even started
everything is up for grabs okay okay
right into Q&A I love it did you always
dream to be on dailyvee
never I didn't know this is gonna happen
in a like a miracle for me
Familia yes odd you made me realize that
I am NOT an interpreter but yes I think
that's a big thing for me so that comes
to my question is that I have a big
ambition I believe education has the
power to change lives and for me my
childhood dream to be a lecturer at a
business folder by his body I really
accomplished it but now for me taking
what's next which is about legacy of a
currency for me and I want to give a
foundation of good schools to give back
to society so one question one thing I
have is that we talked about addition
and the willingness to hustle for it
I have no ambition but the willingness
to hustle for that ambition is lacking
why I asked my question to myself as
well what's the real answer I'll say
this my parents and all that I think
that's a solution
I think biggest thing is myself one that
I am maybe I'm scared of success or a
failure even though I'm comfortable in
uncomfortable
yeah but then I'm not sure that I can do
it really but then it's in time to do
that end of it I think I think the
biggest thing that you you have to I
think both your answers are right I
think once you get into a place where
your failures are just yours they get a
lot less scary and you answered the
right thing whether it's your parents or
somebody else in your life the biggest
reason people don't take risks as they
worry about other people's opinions it
is I I wish you guys could feel what I
feel in my heart and in my soul I do not
care about a single person's point of
view about me while equally caring about
what you think about me it's a very
interesting contradiction
it's a subtlety but saying both your
parents and yourself it's it's you know
when I hear I'm scared to fail but I
feel like I can do it you're just
worrying about you're just worrying
about outside forces it's no different
than the way you like I love if my
professors of 40 50 60 year-olds when I
was 25 would a [ __ ] on me
because I was excited about sticking it
to them later and if I didn't and here's
a big one and I don't talk about this as
much when I fail I'm excited because it
meant that I deserved to fail I love the
game so much even at my own expense
like I can't be pumped about the fruits
of victory without equally respecting
the agony of the defeat
I'm excited when I fail I'm like okay
tough guy and the sleeker the sneaker
this is interesting to me why did I do
this deal
it was win-win if it works I get to run
around with the legacy of being like the
first entrepreneur with a signature
sneaker and then you know it's kind of
cool right like every 20 years
entrepreneurs are just like athletes and
musicians and have sneakers I can sit
here in 20 years and be like you know
the way I thought about the first
speaker you know it's cool it's a it's a
legacy play of being strategically right
but if I fail it's ammo for my friends
to make fun of me like remember when you
thought you were so cool tough guy like
it's funny but I have to have that
humility as much as I have that
confidence to be able to do my thing you
have to be okay with losing I'm a
different question for you which is if
that's your and I agree with you that
education has the chance to change the
world because it's already happened
education change the world my bigger
question is I just want to make sure
that you're not overly romantic of the
format of the delivery of the education
so I'm fascinated by everybody right now
in our current state being energy let me
explain the fact that we in society put
a written handwritten note on a pedestal
as this is some great gesture versus
when we text people is fascinating to me
because we've put the medium on a
pedestal not the action so you're
telling me if I write an incredible
sixth sentence empathetic love letter to
my mom of my admiration of her in text
form that that for some reason is less
powerful than a written handwritten note
for that same delivery just because
we're anti technology because we fear
change
I laugh at that it's how I think about
education I do not believe in a lot of
ways that education is being dispersed
because it is in the selfish financial
interest of the disperser so one weird
insight could be that that's your unlock
that you believe in it but
subconsciously you know that the format
is [ __ ] welcome right thank you
thank you dar James I mean right now are
we like right so I have a client thing
we have to go guys I'm so sorry I have a
client meeting okay thank you for coming
thank you for coming something around
something as unique as that yeah it's
gonna be about patience because people
aren't gonna see it it's gonna take time
debility you know what I mean they're
both very content content content
patience patience patience and execution
just frickin stuff all right thank you
so much Gary welcome to unity see you
soon all right
[Music]
good really good meeting with a client
or potential client or client from a
macro level a big corporate client that
has an office here kind of talked about
our ambitions in the Southeast Asian
market and so there's an awfully
productive trip I also get awfully
ambitious when I'm in new territory
I just wanted to transcribe all of my
content into every language in the
Warthog I'm also thinking it's 1257 and
we've done more than a full day's worth
of work for most people
we have another 14 hours to go
there was odd weird like that home baby
phone home d-roc
I appreciate it though hopefully thank
you so much everything that comes out of
something that's already been awesome in
its a I'm not worried about the results
I'm worried about the setup you know
tomorrow every single person can get
different product in the newsfeed go
into Facebook search type in soccer and
football like 400 pictures and videos
from soccer and watch your newsfeed
change tomorrow type in Chiang kai-shek
and like everything and watch your
newsfeed change tomorrow
type in Beyonce tomorrow type in
pineapple tomorrow type in red watches
and watch your newsfeed change
Facebook's not manipulating you you're
manipulating Facebook it's time to take
ownership so you're physically to begin
as a serial that's a fast so how do you
know if an idea works you know
you know you make an intuitive call on
the jockey and the horse you got to like
the person you got to like the idea some
things work out some don't venmo I love
the idea I love the operator they were
good enough to get it to a certain point
but then they had to sell because they
couldn't take it to the next level and
now it's one of the most valuable
companies in the world but I didn't make
any money the Utica for everybody it's a
good field
let me explain by that it makes Lena
a lot of BC's invest on data that is
projected data that's called gut feel
they want to be fancy and be in those
tall buildings and wear a suit and say
that they make decisions on analytics
but if you're making a decision on pure
math you should be right 100 percent at
a time so what are these B C's guessing
on guessing
you got it no problem
Thank You mr. Garre you're welcome come
take a picture let's do it selfie
awesome so nice to meet you thank you
well here's why I'm really really good
at what I do 90% of the media I consume
in my life
is reading people's comments on the
content that I put out
I basically spend my life on consumer
behavior and reaction to content [ __ ]
you soon okay great yeah no problem
that was a lot of fun I like I like
those kind of talks vaynernation squad I
want to give you guys a huge shout out
big love I appreciate it
I'm flattered by it I really don't know
what else to say
and what else we want to tell well just
keep hustling keep working hard keep
grinding keep listening to everything
that carries don't don't listen to what
I say watch what I do that's the key
anyways sending my love thank you guys
in the community for all of it see ya
[Music]
thank you sir of course of course hello
hello hi Gary
hi nice to meet you how are you hello hi
here see Gary how are you yes what an
influencer what you guys offer is a
total different context and a total
different affiliation for a brand so do
I think brands should spend on Instagram
I do do i think they should also spend
on kayo else I do because the people
that follow her or him or her have an
affinity to that person I mean there's
always been a reason why sponsorship and
endorsement and people affiliation
always works and so I don't think it's a
either I don't think it's an either/or I
think it's a both you also have to
understand that Facebook is six months
away from making sure they make a 20%
big on everything everybody does which
will then allow them to be very
comfortable with you making money as
long as they're making their tax I think
what kayo else have to do it is be more
thoughtful about how they promote it
blows my mind that people that are in a
position to make millions of dollars a
year are willing to take $40,000 from a
detox tea and give that all away I test
everything you know first of all and I
think you've all seen this creative is
the variable of success you know the
better you get at this craft at growth
hacking growing best practices we all
done stuff with best practices hashtags
titles on YouTube first three seconds
pre really we've all done stuff every
day over the years that you've been
doing it whether a year or ten years you
do something that you didn't expect to
happen cuz the creative was the variable
and the creative is grey not black and
white
and that's why testing is everything I
basically think I'm in full testing mode
always I accept nothing I'm constantly
innovating everything I'm doing
because and don't forget we're spending
you know vaynermedia spending 300
million dollars a year on Facebook ads
like I'm looking at real data not just
my own and it's the creative and best
practices and continuity and and then
and then it's just the things that come
native to you right like collaborations
so important like so many of you right
now should take a picture with each
other and post cross clap like it's such
a benefit it's just such lightweight ROI
you you know like so there's a lot
there's a lot it's a heavy matrix and
then once you get into that place where
you're selling stuff you know how much
value you have to give and return to
convert properly when you ask you know
there's all these variables I wrote a
book called Jab Jab Jab right hook and
it was about give give give and then ask
and that cadence of how much you're
giving versus you're asking return is
probably the most philosophical
importance of where you'll probably go
going forward like when you become a
personal brand when you miss balance
giving versus asking you are finished
you're on that you're on the start of
the process of going in the other
direction because everybody's about to
be a personal brand give as much as you
can you know what my thesis is guilt
them into get buying because you give
them so much I'm in full guilt mode like
I'm in full guilt strategy you know
Gary you always talk about getting out
of your comfort zone yeah is so
important Oh Singapore so I want to see
if we can get you out of yours have you
heard of durian oh my god I have the
moon I have been dying I have been dying
to try this really yes so you see this
in all the extreme food stuff I am so
curious what's about guys this is a big
deal for me actually well I think for
most the smell okay good bad what do you
think well this is banned on the subong
oh god this is good it's bad it's super
interesting it's literally banned
because it's so strong yeah so we
brought you some durian do you eat
durian
I've never had it myself so I've been
I've been afraid I've lived here a year
and a half and I've been afraid okay no
no okay and it's real yeah but it's cool
all right so what are we doing
how much do you eat like it's all now
you gotta go for more than that I'm
gonna be good with it like I think I
think this is how much you're supposed
to eat you hate that you got it all
right then you 10 you mmm it's good
you weren't ready for it I really wasn't
I kind of like it but I was obviously
cautious with the volume I'm kind of
okay with that you got a plunge Gary you
got a fire I mean it's a weird stuff man
you did it man congratulations I'm good
with that
but it smells it's wild stuff are you
punky at least now tried yeah I'm pumped
are you devastated that you were
defeated and I was unbelievably
remarkable oh it's not a competition my
friends everything is a competition all
right everything I'm not no
congratulations great to see you again
bye guys
[Music]
I hope you go I hope I see good
insurance with light small radiant than
the Sun you say you won't you know if
you go my website right now these it
says that I day trade attention that's
what I do the end its day trading
attention and it's it's so much more
real than people real wish are you guys
familiar with wish the shopping app wish
has gone from zero to anywhere between
five to seven billion dollars on
transactional sales on their platform on
a hundred percent Facebook arbitrage
they've already moved they know it's
starting to mature and if you look at
what they're doing there's a logo on the
Lakers Jersey if you watch the MacGregor
Mayweather fight they did Brant now
they're doing above the now there
doesent branding they did sales
conversion now they're moving the
branding as it's maturing but it's still
grossly underpriced KO else I would tell
you ko ELLs and and influencers is the
great misunderstood marketplace right
now for any business including very
boring b2b SAS businesses it's just a
tension that's under priced
[Music]
always it's the variable of success once
you figure out where the attentions
underpriced
google was great for analytical people
because of his blue letters and it was
intent-based Facebook is television and
so you have to be dramatically more
creative to arbitrage Facebook which is
why a lot of analytical people have
struggled and then all the big brands I
always pointed because Unilever but like
okay I apologize but but but this is who
I work with all the big brands they're
there in television all the Qantas
marketers are struggling with the
creative variable and you have this
dichotomy and that's why Facebook is
still so vibrant for underpriced
opportunity yes attention spans and
mostly there are certain digital
properties that are grabbing feminine
attention span space and but there's a
long and ephemeral side and then there's
associated yeah and I think you know I
think people are too hyper critical
ephemeral because of femorals like how
the world actually works I agree 100%
but was I you know what's ironic
obviously snapchat had its real moment
with ephemeral that's far more similar
to the way everything has been done
prior televisions ephemeral magazines
ephemeral direct mails ephemeral yeah
it's like it's ephemeral like it's you
know every this tonight's ephemeral you
know like a hundred percent it's
in the blink of an eye and I just wanna
know
you'll be there by my side and dicken
feel so home
[Music]
the one day your heart make it home it's
gonna go in the blink of an eye and I
just wanna know
[Music]
so I just wanna I just want to thank
everybody for coming out tonight
I'm sure there's a lot of other things
you could be doing and I'm very
flattered I'm glad I got to say hello to
everybody real quick and I'm looking
forward to yeah Jesus that's a big beer
and and I'm excited to talk to a bunch
of you I've had an incredible two full
days very full days thank you Raisa for
packing my schedule for 18 [ __ ] hours
a day and d-roc and I are gonna be very
happy to leave in an hour so and finally
get to the airport and go to sleep but
I've really enjoyed it we uh maybe
you've heard we have some seriously
ambitions of opening an office here so I
have a funny feeling I'll be seeing you
guys around and and thank you so much
for the hospitality I think the the
entrepreneurial spirit the class the
grit it's been it's been very fruitful
I've really enjoyed it and I'm really
I'm really looking forward to saying
hello and getting to know some of you
guys tonight and if not fully tonight
I'm sure hopefully in the future so I
wish you guys nothing but good health
and all the good stuff and I hope you
have a nice night thanks for coming out
the only mentor I've ever had is you
guys the market the market is my mentor
the market is my religion the consumer
has been my guide from a little kid
lemonade like it's crazy now that I've
learned you know it's a you know you
know how you're starting to get even in
your 20s you're starting to understand
yourself better when I think back to
what I did as a kid how consumers sent
baseball card shows you know sports
memorabilia right I would do something
now I'm like oh my god everybody would
set up their table you know before the
mall or the Convention Center would open
you set up your table your booth I
didn't I would never set up I would walk
the entire floor context
who's pricing what what do people have
on their tables is it football cards and
baseball cards is there a certain player
that's hot then I would went for the
first hour and watch what people did
bless you at those tables then I would
go set up so I've been lit you know it's
funny I talk so much right like sit down
talk like but I'm listening a lot so my
mentor is the game the market will go to
my hotel right to get bags hey guys it's
a 1106 d-roc I have no idea how you're
planning on editing this episode but you
better [ __ ] show the fact that I've
been [ __ ] talking and taking
questions and answers for the last
[ __ ] 14 straight hours I will punch
you in the nose if you don't show it
this was a real [ __ ] grinder
Singapore
[Music]
your heart make it fall
[Music]
all right good all right guys it's your
favorite moment with every vlog this
time I really need it do you know about
the greatest action hero of all time
you're looking at one of the great
transformations when I go from a mere
mortal man to the great superhero of our
generation
this is what I turn into Airport Gary
tentative then I have music there's
music playing right now oh yeah there's
music now I am rejuvenated and
unstoppable
[Music]
[Applause]